[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i love you so [ __ ] much oh my god he
actually honestly i would love you so
much but you'd be one of those ones
one of the ones where if i walked into
you know me in my bedroom from the road
right and you're eating her butthole
right yeah you're eating her butthole
yeah you shot me on the can yeah no yeah
i would be like oh
night
he's really good at it all right dude
let's stop
but stop and then
i'd walk you out into the hallway i got
dude i'm gonna let that pass right but
just don't do it again yeah no problem
no problem yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you have any uh do you have any
kleenex
yeah you can take this the wrong way but
um the truth is that if i see a like
like that the the movie the cove
where the dolphins are being slaughtered
in that bay yeah i get hungry for
dolphins
he pissed off his wife in the video game
and now she's not talking to him
no well what happened was and he i had
to hear it for a full hour today no no
what happened no
there's no consequences what happened
hayley of pink cake and haley i'm trying
to offer my relationships with you maybe
she hasn't what is this
it's a farming simulation game called
stardew valley and i've been playing it
for 16 hours a day oh okay yeah you won
an academy award someday
don't be hard on yourself who are your
parents the most racist about growing up
yeah
well did they based no they based it on
they owned a clothing store called
fashion gal
it was basically like you know
lame brine for ethnic people so samoans
okay but every once in a while indians
would walk in and they wouldn't buy
anything so i heard that a lot
they don't buy nothing
but they come in they look around they
look around they look you know i mean
and you hear it and you're like all
right dad but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they're you know cockroaches
you know
or he did do a list of like you know
one time he made a list of like who the
hierarchy had the hierarchy of well
who's not who's at the top koreans yeah
well naturally and then who's second
place the second were uh oddly enough
japanese yeah really yeah the asians
like korean to give them yeah because
they give it
in terms of like economic strength okay
and their their position in the world
and all that stuff yeah
number three was chinese
okay okay
number four was um
snakes
yeah and number five was mexicans
there were like animals in between it
you know yeah and then my black friends
go where were we on the list i got it
the only list was up to 100.
yeah
i have a story that people don't believe
that i did because yeah i think how dumb
are you
right and um
but it's that's why i'm afraid to tell
the story because it doesn't seem like
it's real what did you do
so i was with kalila
and we were in a hawaiian trip
but then we
ran into
a school of jellyfish
so then i had bumps from the top of my
head down to my feet where you swam into
it yeah you can see it but they're
translucent it's a school you can see a
lot of them i don't open my eyes when
i'm in the water you don't no i'm like
you know i get scared do you open your
eyes under water
yeah we wear a mask yeah i didn't wear a
mask oh you should i was just like you
mean
you know and we but everyone ran into
them
like you kalila everyone right yeah so
we're with these two white dudes and
they're like ocean photographers mm-hmm
you know like you know like the ones
with the
with the abs
the hot guys
that's what i wanted to say yeah hot
guys sexy hot guys like surfer bros
right so we were all standing around
they're like i go i i'm so itchy
like we're all yet to do just urine
right you have to pee on yourself
but i didn't it's no so what they they
pulled their dicks out these guys yeah
and they started peeing into a cup
drink it
well that's what happened so i
so what happened was no yes no so i go
oh i'm not gonna do it with you guys i'm
just gonna go behind so i went behind
like a tree
and i peed in the thing
and then i drank it
no and then when it came back i saw them
putting it on their body
and i go oh it goes on the body and
they're like what'd you do with it i go
i know a lot came out you know i mean so
i didn't even do it it's in the body
it's in the body now when i tell that
story yeah i told that story on stage
and no one believed me i mean i believe
it knowing you i i believe you believe
it yeah okay
yeah right away good yeah
korean dads
don't have a lot of emotion no
they don't yeah and some people be like
oh but that's kind of [ __ ] up yeah i
don't think it's if when you said ah it
reminded me like whenever i would
introduce my dad to like a new friend
from high school
i go hey dad this is tony he would go
like okay okay yeah
like i don't want to know his name you
know i get it you know and he would also
do this with his name
awake i knew he would do that for you
because he knew you were going to be in
the kitchen kissing the dude
he's like
hey i don't lie
i'm not gay i know you're not yeah yeah
i'm okay real quick if you love comedy
you want to support the art form we're
featuring a new up and coming comedian
on our instagram everyday go check it
out link and bio follow us on there
we'll send you some free stickers bye is
there a face that you make when i orgasm
yeah
you know what it is oh yeah i go like
this oh
it's real subtle it's not subtle it's
so racist is that racist it's overtly
racist no it's not it's not subtle that
has nothing to do with race overly
racist no i'm i just get really i really
get it it's like if ladies and gentlemen
anyone that does that the the president
of the united states is focusing like oh
that's me orgasm it's it's no that's me
orgasm it's overtly racist that's me
that's not racist why would it be have
anything to do with race you ask for my
faces and i go oh
that's what i do it's like if i orgasm
i'd do a white thing hey buddy that's so
funny yeah
hey buddy
gotcha
or whatever
when they say dolphins are the smartest
sea mammals they are right they have sex
for fun then why like for me it's like
if i'm
swimming into a bay
and it's blood
there's blood yeah i'm going the other
direction like it's like walking down an
alleyway and you see blood in alley when
you see a guy getting stabbed yeah you
would you know he's like go the other
way
yeah just keep walking walk the other
way 100 so how bright are they really
well they're going to save their friend
they want to know what is he okay yeah
they're there can they do a different
noise
yeah i don't like the kick
do a different noise yo
what do you want don't make it don't
make it
hey man why it's not how's that urban
all right maybe hey man maybe they won't
hey man that hurts dog hey what wait
what's that dog see don't add dog it's a
dog doing it a dog is killing me
yeah that's why it's in it
yeah i don't know they do need a
different noise do your dolphin
that's really good that's wow that was
really good guess what don't laugh who'd
you swim with
dolphins
did you
yeah yeah you swam with dolphins and
there was a baby
could you stand on their nose can they
push your feet right is that what they
do yeah but we didn't i did that in
mexico one time yeah i mean i don't i
wasn't with them you know what i do yeah
i ride them you get on top oh yeah they
let me they'll stop
right now
and i'll get on their back right did you
do what the blowhole
well that's how i get locked into the
scene
you ride it backwards yeah you gotta
lock in yeah yeah i get locked in yeah
no try to stay away from those things
when you did summer camp with the gang
the game yeah i don't know i should
consider that to be racist
the game why can it be some of your
fellow friends yeah why can't it be was
if a white man was here
yeah yo bobby if a white man was here
yeah i would have said gang
yeah i mean
i would have said gang my friend you
would even said fellowship no no i would
have said gang that because i'm a simple
guy and you you're a gang of thieves i'm
not i'm not
talking to pirates or what a gang of
friends i mean i would love to go back
through i don't know i don't know why
i don't know why i would love to go back
i'm up against the wall
old kaleilas where you dripping whacked
off yeah for the first time my life and
um it did a fountain which it was
upsetting because that means never does
foundation not in marshmallow he always
does like a weepy little dollop
no projectile fondue yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i went uh and it went
on the thing it looked like i had
[ __ ] icing on the tip of my phone yes
like it was one of those fancy um like
cupcake pops yes
you made a cake pop yeah i did a kickbox
and i uh you know what it's a weird
master being in the bathtub though it's
really weird it is good
because you're swimming with your [ __ ] i
don't know i know
but i've done it i i don't know and you
you drink you stand you sit with your
with all the come on you're right and
you have bubbles yeah then you have to
just go [ __ ] it you know what i mean and
then you see them swimming around yeah
and they're very good they come fields
and water it's like oil and water it
kind of feels like um you know when you
have cornstarch in your hand and you do
this yeah no i know i know
it's about grainy but squeaky squeaky is
the word i would say oh yeah i think you
got really big sperm
[Music]
you know we belong to a country club
uh-huh so our the country club that we
belong to was called the stone ridge
country club and every once in a while
we get pros come by
okay
and one day michael chang is that his
name
he was just playing with because i took
a class there
right and we were able to we all took
turns playing with him that's awesome
and that's my michael ching's story
michael chang is the ultimate journeyman
because he wants to cut that out that
story sucks
it was great suck my dick that story i
was i teared up
put that in the books
you know i mean did he hit hard like did
he no you shut the [ __ ] up
talk about caps he had power
i want to say something this is one of
those situations where i was going to
tell that michael chang story before the
phone call
and so in my head i'm like just let it
go there's nothing there
my thought process let it go there's
nothing there right so the
the phone call kept going with your mom
and whatnot right and i'm like
should i let it go or not yeah let's
just throw it out there see what happens
right and once it's
nothing right and then i felt like
disgust and shame as a kid put my penis
oh
go on my hands and knees like this right
yeah
i go to my hands and leaves like this
right
and then i would stick my penis in me on
the faucet i would turn it on
and and the way the water hit my penis
it would make me erect
right yeah
and so and i would i would jerk off a
little bit like this how close did you
have to get real close i'll bet huh
to what deposit yeah no that's it felt
good because of the distance between the
faucet and my penis oh gotcha just that
it was a perfect you know i think it was
too close but the pressure would have
been hurtful yeah right he's talking
about close to the wall yeah because did
the water just go between your penis and
the wall
it's a small dick joke but i know i know
i don't know i was just trying to defend
myself but no thank you i was just
trying to affect him he really and then
this is what i so one day i was doing it
and this is what i hear
right and then i stopped jerking yeah
and i turned my head like this yeah and
my dad's going
laughing and laughing at me
and he just walked out of the bathtub
and we've never talked about it
it's not one of those things your dad's
still with us yeah he's still with us
mom too yeah okay and um i've never
brought it up again well yeah i don't
yeah yeah because he's only laughed like
that twice
that time can i just say you were
holding up three fingers right then
when you said twice you said he's only
done that he's only left like that twice
yeah i have carpal tunnel okay so
no i'm sorry like twice that's still
three
it doesn't [ __ ] matter okay okay you
know it's fine
right and the second time he did that is
when i was in rehab
and i told him in front of the whole
rehab that i was molested by a guy with
down syndrome and he laughed like that
too
in front of everybody your whole family
my whole family left
so those are the two and so people ask
me how come you're so glam and moody
that's why
that's the origin that's it
[Music]
i'm gonna let you know right now i don't
have a heart on